I was editing the podcast not long ago
and I don't know if you remember this
but in one of the intros we had a
conversation where you were talking
about how you told your dad when you're
eating a meal like I don't I don't like
this and your dad said I don't I don't
know what you like no he said why should
I care what you like and don't like yeah
but you despite all of our little
sibling rivalry we have here you know I
think you're a very funny guy
you did this voice on there or you're
you're that age Conan telling your
father what you like and I was editing
and I was rolling do you
remember I don't remember the voice
oh oh that guy
and what I really like to do is when I'm
really doing a prissy young fellow I
like to say instead of Father the Latin
potato
[Laughter]
and I have a little bell
yes son what is it
um
it should be clear now I know I'm one of
six and I'm in the middle
but I think you know by now I'm not a
fan of half and half I like two percent
well having half is just a little too
thick but two percent it gets it just
right it's not quite as viscous s-a-t
word
you
lousy Punk oh Potter
don't catch her don't get your panties
in a bunch pot here
come here come here I'll smash you you
have to catch me first
I've got one of those old-timey bicycles
with a giant front wheel it's called a
philosophied or a penny farthing if you
will I'm getting upon it right now and
you'll have to catch me
then I'm zipping around the room my
father's in his lab coat trying to catch
me can hear you hurry
two percent is on the money for me one
percent's too thin half and half's too
thick I love that the other five
children are 100 normal children and
you're the only one in that family who
wears a little Beanie I will tell you a
true story which is
this is an absolutely true story about
uh my brother Luke we lived in Brookline
Massachusetts and we would walk there
was this store that we would go to uh it
was like a small Grocery and our parents
would send us my mom would send us an
errands like can you go get some
hamburger can you get this can you get
that and the store was in this one area
where these like they're these tougher
kids like the Irish Catholic kids that
played hockey which my brother and I
definitely were not they were the ones
that played hockey and they kind of knew
those are those weird kids their
father's like a scientist and they read
and they uh they and I think we kind of
stuck out and they thought we were
strange and so we were walking over my
brother Luke is very very highly
intelligent he's really smart and he was
really very precocious at that age and
uh much smarter than I was and still
much smarter than I am and we would
we walked into Star Market one day and
these tough kids came over and they kind
of half surrounded us and they were sort
of pushing us and the thing to say at
least in our town in those days was if
you wanted to say something negative
about someone you say what are you
mental and Luke actually said to them
well
mental is Latin and it implies of the
mind so that's kind of a compliment
thank you very much bam
the beating that ensued lasted for 20
minutes I was on your side till he said
that yeah Summer's Here of course summer
is the time for everything fresh let me
list a few fresh air refreshing
vacations and plenty of hellofresh to
laughing up Meals that's where I was
going hello fresh and with Chef crafted
seasonal recipes and new fresh and fit
summer menu hello fresh brings you
flavor right to your door yeah and now's
the peak time for summer produce hello
fresh make sure you get all the best
picks all season long delicious fresh
meals mmm well make your home the place
to be this summer pre-proportioned
ingredients that help cut down on food
waste and time while step-by-step
Instructions make cooking a breeze not a
chore hello fresh combines quality and
convenience with ingredients making it
from the farm to your door in less than
seven days Sona hello fresh saved your
life I don't know if it saved my life as
a cook you're a disaster on your own but
when Hello fresh is involved it's
fantastic I didn't think that was the
case but yeah I really like hello fresh
I did sent me three meals one was a
chicken one was a pork and one was a
fish yeah and fantastic I crushed it
yeah and I remember going to your house
once for dinner before you used hello
fresh and you served me one meatball on
an ice cream cone yeah no that's not a
meal but hellofreshed is it totally
upped your game congratulations Sona
that was a good meatball uh no I'm not
sure that was meat anyway
go to hellofresh.com Team coco50 and use
code Team Coco 50 for 50 off plus free
shipping that's team coco50 at
hellofresh.com teamcoco50 for 50 off
plus free shipping America's number one
meal kit but I mean you know I do
remember that I know and you know Luke
Luke weighed all of like 80 pounds and
uh I probably weighed 81 pounds and he
was older than me but he had like I
don't know he had been a little sickly
so anyway it was just absolutely what do
you do when your brother you just
hide oh I I think I said I don't know
him
oh no even though we look identical yeah
you guys look so much alike yeah people
did think we were twins practically but
I was I think I pretty much had a
standard line which is I don't know this
man
um I'll help you hit him and yes if
anyone gets tired hitting him uh I'm a
pretty good hitter here's the stick yeah
yeah exactly you know you don't have to
use your fist
there's some rocks over here that way
you don't bruise your knuckles
and and then Luke of course at the
bottom of the pile would say well rocks
are actually
more uh they're denser than the actual
bone of a fist so I think Conan's got a
good point
you know the Greeks believed
yeah yeah yeah what are you mental well
Latin does Empire yes and then I'd run
home to tell my father Potter
some hooligans are thrashing Luke which
one's Luke
Luke is the one one year older than I
but a year separates us
six he is two and I am three oh Potter
what a thrashing he's taking
I don't have time to do anything what am
I supposed to do about it I'm a
microbiologist father you say you're a
microbiologist why you sound like a
prize fighter
lousy by the way did you pick up that
two percent
at the time at the time yeah
yeah I love you
still smarter and better than me but man
I shouldn't have whipped out that Latin
in front of those hockey players and for
that I mean that's on you man